neutrinos sind wahre geister teilchen
sie sind elektrisch gesehen neutral und
haben eine sehr geringe masse fest steht
die teilchen haben keinerlei interesse
daran mit der materie wie wir sie kennen
in kontakt zu treten
doch jetzt hat ein forschungsteam eine
überraschende entdeckung gemacht unsere
erde stockt die neutrinos aus den tiefen
des alls und das obwohl sie ja
eigentlich gar nicht zu stoppen sind wie
das physik team unsere erde als
gigantischen neutrino killer
identifiziert hat ob er jetzt
tatsächlich eine neue physik brauchen
und was wir in zukunft mit den neutrinos
über die erde erfahren können jetzt in
kriegs und science und fiction tat sich
willkommen
nicht zu unrecht werden neutrinos als
geister teilchen bezeichnet ihre masse
ist äußerst gering für die erkenntnis
dass sie überhaupt eine haben bekamen
das entsprechende forschungsteam 2015
den nobelpreis für physik
die geister teilchen gehen nur wirklich
selten eine wechselwirkung mit der
materie wie wir sie kennen ein weil sie
eben nicht interagieren rasen sie
ungestört durchs all doch jetzt steht
fest neutrinos können materie nicht
einfach so ungehindert passieren
das haben jetzt erstmalig messungen des
sogenannten ice cubes gezeigt dass
unsere thorium namens ice cube das zur
amerikanischen amundsen scott
forschungsstation am südpol wird ist
wohl eines der spannendsten experimente
weltweit 5160 sensoren wurden dafür tief
in den antarktischen untergrund versenkt
und zwar bis zu 2,5 kilometer tief
zusammen bilden sie ein riesiges
dreidimensionales würfelförmiges
detector fällt echt wahnsinn hier soll
die sogenannte cherenkov strahlung
erforscht werden damit ist das leuchten
gemeint dass durch die kollision von
neutrinos mit den wassermolekülen des
eises entstehen das passiert nicht oft
schätzungsweise ein paar tausend mal im
jahr doch wenn es passiert dann richtig
pro sekunde prallen zwischen 68 und 100
milliarden euro - auf jeden
quadratzentimeter der erde ein sie
stammen aus der sonne oder etwa
gigantischen ereignis im weltall wie
supernova explosionen oder gammastrahlen
ausbrüchen und ihre unfassbare
beschleunigung kann man sich eigentlich
gar nicht vorstellen in der aktuellen
untersuchung wurden tatsächlich
neutrinos mit einer energie achtung von
980 tera elektronenvolt analysiert zum
vergleich im lhc des genfer
kernforschungszentrum cern also dem
large hadron collider sind protonen mit
energien von 13
tera elektronenvolt am start und noch
eine ziemlich krasse rand sind es
mittlerweile wurden mit hilfe des ice
cubes auch schon teilchen im bereich von
peter elektronenvolt gemessen also mehr
als 1000 tera elektronenvolt
das forschungsteam hat jetzt daten aus
dem zeitraum von mai 2010 bis mai 2011
ausgewertet insgesamt haben sie 11.000
kollisionen im eis analysiert die
entsprechenden neutrinos waren mit den
wassermolekülen am südpol in der
umgebung
ice cube kollidiert zunächst analysierte
das forschungsteam den ursprung der hoch
energetischen neutrinos die den detektor
erreicht hatten das ergebnis ist eine
sensation denn die wenigsten teilchen
kamen aus der richtung aus der die
neutrinos vorab die komplette erde
durchqueren mussten hier wurden
offensichtlich viele von ihnen auf ihrem
weg abgebremst dazu einer der forscher
davon unsere resultate zeigen zum ersten
mal dass neutrinos mit sehr hoher
energie von etwas absorbiert werden
können in diesem fall von der erde
das ist etwas das bisher noch nie
experimentell nachgewiesen werden konnte
überrascht hat aber auch noch eine
weitere erkenntnis vor allem die sehr
schnelle neutrinos crashten mit den
wassermolekülen überraschend weil das
bisher nur für diejenigen geister
teilchen experimentell nachgewiesen
werden konnte die eher langsamer
unterwegs waren der grund die leistung
der teilchenbeschleuniger reicht nur für
niedrige energien aus dennoch der
zusammenhang schnelle neutrinos dann
große wahrscheinlichkeit für kollision
entspricht voll und ganz dem
standardmodell der teilchenphysik
demnach nimmt die zahl der neutrino
kollision mit atomen zu je höher die
energie ist dazu francis herzen der chef
des ice cube experiments wir hatten
natürlich gehofft dass wir eine art
neuer für sich sähen würden aber wir
haben unglücklicherweise sehen dass das
standardmodell die üblich den test
besteht ja viele physiker und
physikerinnen hatten sich wohl hinweise
auf exotische teilchen oder extra
dimensionen gewünscht es ist schon
frappierend im moment scheint die
forschung dann wirklich festzustecken ob
hier im ice cube oder am large hadron
collider dem lhc in genf es wird nichts
neues gefunden und das standardmodell
der teilchenphysik wird immer nur
bestätigt doch trotzdem sind diese
ergebnisse sehr interessant in zukunft
wäre es denkbar dass neutrinos
informationen über das erdinnere liefern
beispielsweise über die wärme des
vulkanismus oder den zerfall von uran
ja und wenn er kein video zu diesen
themen und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann drücken wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch
immer über neue videos informiert hier
geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
herkunft der geister teilchen enträtselt
auch sehr sehr spannend ansonsten bis
dann bleib dran